When you log into your computer at work,
you're probably providing a username, a
password, and perhaps some other type of
authentication credential. When you go
home and you want to connect back to the
corporate network using a VPN, you use
exactly the same username and password.
How does the system at work know use
exactly the same login credentials as
your VPN client at home? It's able to do
this by using a centralized
authentication server and specialized
authentication protocols. Let's take the
scenario where you are authenticating to
a VPN concentrator from home. In this
scenario, we have your laptop at home.
We have a VPN concentrator. This is
probably also a firewall used by your
company. There's also behind this
firewall an authentication server and
ultimately the internal file server that
you would like to access. The first step
is you at your laptop at home sending a
login request to the VPN concentrator.
That login request is going to have your
username and your password. The VPN
concentrator doesn't have any of this
authentication information to verify
from. So, it sends this request down to
an authentication server asking to see
if the username and password is correct.
The authentication server will evaluate
your login credentials and if they are
correct, it will send a message back
saying that those credentials have been
approved. At that point, the VPN
concentrator allows you access to the
inside of the network because it was
able to verify that you use the proper
authentication credentials. There are a
number of different protocols that can
be used between a device and an
authentication server in order to
validate those credentials. And in this
video, we'll step through a number of
the most popular protocols in use.
You'll sometimes hear these
authentication protocols referred to as
AAA protocols or the server that it's
connecting to as a AAA server. That AAA
stands for authentication,
authorization, and accounting. And one
of the most popular AAA protocols is
radius. This stands for remote
authentication dialin user service.
Although dialin is in the name of the
protocol, this is a type of protocol
that can be used on any standard
network. We would commonly have a radius
server where all of these authentication
credentials are stored. This would allow
us to centrally authenticate if we were
connecting to a router, a switch, or a
firewall. Or perhaps we're
authenticating into a server or
accessing a VPN concentrator. Or once
you get into the office, maybe you're
using those login credentials to access
an 802.11 wireless network. Across all
of these different devices and all of
these different services, we're using
exactly the same login credentials.
thanks to Radius. Radius has been around
for quite some time and you'll find
clients and servers that are able to use
Radius on many different operating
systems. Another popular authentication
protocol is TACax. This is
TACS. This stands for terminal access
controller access control system. This
was a very early form of authentication
that was used to control access to
dialup lines to the early form of the
internet known as arponet. Tacax has
been updated through the years and a
modern version of tacax is known as
tacax plus. Tacax plus provided
additional authentication capabilities
and more response code details and it
was released as an open standard in
1993. Tacax was widely used with Cisco
switches and Cisco routers and even
today many people associate Tacax with
Cisco. If you've ever logged into a
Windows domain then you've probably
logged in using the Kerarose protocol.
Keraros is a technology that allows you
to authenticate one time and then you
are trusted by the entire system for a
certain time frame. This means you can
log in one time in the morning and you
can access all of the resources you need
on the network without putting in your
username and password every time you
connect to a new resource. Keraros uses
cryptography to provide mutual
authentication. So you're not only
authenticating with a server, the server
may also be authenticating with you.
This provides additional protection
against on path attacks or replay
attacks that may be used against you.
And although Keraros has been around
since the 1980s, it was first developed
at MIT, it's now part of the Windows
operating system. So anytime you're
logging in with Windows, you're using
Kerros. Behind the scenes, when you
first log in to the network, you're
requesting a login to something called a
ticket granting service, and it's giving
you a service ticket once you've
authenticated properly. This means that
you now have the ability to connect to
many different resources on the network
by simply showing your service ticket to
all of those different resources. This
means you can save time by not having to
constantly input your username and
password to all of these different
devices. But once you go outside of that
Windows ecosystem, you may find that
other devices don't understand Keraros
and are not able to authenticate with
that protocol. For that reason, you may
find yourself adding on additional
technologies so that you can still have
single sign on even in a non-winds
environment. So you might be using smart
cards, SAML or some other type of
technology for
authentication. So now you've heard
about the use of many different
authentication protocols. The question
then becomes which protocol do you use
and in which scenario? Different
organizations have different
requirements. They might have different
authentication servers already set up
and the technologies that you're using
may only be able to communicate using
one of those different authentication
methods. For example, you may be
installing a VPN concentrator and that
VPN concentrator only knows how to
authenticate to a Radius server. It may
be that that VPN software doesn't
understand how to authenticate using
Keraros or using Tacax. And it might be
that your organization already has a
Radius server which is a perfect match
for this VPN software which can only
authenticate to a Radius server. Or you
may find that an organization is using
Tacax Plus for authentication. And you
may find that that organization has a
large infrastructure of Cisco devices.
And if you're logging in and using
Keraros for authentication, it's very
likely your organization is using
Microsoft Windows. Although there are
advantages and disadvantages to all of
these different authentication types,
usually we pick the authentication type
that makes the most sense for our
existing
infrastructure. I mentioned earlier that
you might be authenticating using a
username, a password, and then some
other type of authentication factor. If
you're using multiple factors during the
login process, we refer to that as
multiffactor authentication. So you
might be using something you are which
is some type of biometric like a
fingerprint or you may be using
something you have. This might be your
mobile phone and you're using an app on
your mobile phone to get a code that you
can use during the login process.
Another type of authentication factor is
something you know. Most often this is
something like a password or a personal
identification number. You could also be
using the factor of somewhere you are.
There might be GPS or some type of
location services that can verify that
you might be inside of a building or
within a particular country. And very
often we're using an authentication
method that is something you do. If
you've ever had to sign to receive a
delivery, then you've authenticated
using something you do. Some of these
authentication methods may be relatively
expensive. For example, something you
have may require you to have an external
hardware token that you carry around
with you. Or it might be relatively
inexpensive. It might be a free
application you load on an existing
mobile phone and you have something you
have as an additional authentication
factor.